you can see here everything's in the
same base that's kind of nice right so
what am I gonna do I want to turn it
into adding and subtracting and then I
wouldn't use my adding and subtracting
to combine three logs into one and then
I appreciate I can simplify from them
okay so for instance first long this is
the reverse of the powell or isn't it so
what's that to gonna do it's going to
come out to the top it'll become 10
squared so that would be log base 5 of
what a hundred that's 110 Spanish okay
then over here I've got subtraction when
you subtract logs you divide what's
happening in the middle right so this is
going to be plus log base 5 of 50
divided by 40 which is 5 over 4 ok so
far so good when I add logs I'm out
another step right when I add logs I
multiply what's happening inside right
so I've got a hundred times five over
four 100 and the four they can cancel
some stuff there the fort's gonna cancel
leave me we have 25 so I have 25 times 5
which is 125 hey I recognize that how
long do I have to stick it in my five
time career machine so against 125 it's
up three minutes because 5 cubed is 125
okay do you see how I just tried to go
like don't be overwhelmed by this just
look at each individual piece to see
what you can do and it kind of unfolds
from there right okay
I was the other one you asked people
right okay this time you tell me what's
alone
somebody hasn't said anything yet give
me a suggestion what can I do
okay so I've got 1/2 here or you tweet
at this number here 320 what do you want
to do with that ok so I've got 2 log
base 4 of 20 to the power of 1/2 I can
do that
excuse me what about this guy what can I
do with him yeah I can do the reverse
there by the way can you see why it's
like hold on wait what why are you doing
one thing here and you're doing the
opposite there do you see why actually
sometimes we'll do the opposite
25 just square number right so taking
the square root is easy
where is 20s like these are the new
nights on the square root of 20 years no
one knows what it is so therefore I want
to get rid of the 1/2 there but I want
to put it in here so this is going to
turn into log base 4 off 25 the power of
1/2 which is the square root 25 which is
5 ok next step
tell me what to do so that 1/2 is going
to come out the front with the power law
cancel with the two it just leaves you
with that right and I've got this guy at
the front he hasn't he hasn't changed
okay and then yes because I've only
fired take away 20 its 5/20 right so I'm
gonna go log base 4 of what 5 on 20
which is a quart excuse me a quart up
okay one last it what do I do it to you
could go straight to according this if
you wanted
good this is for the power piggies one
so the negative one can come out the
front and it's times log base 4 of 4
will be left which is just one I'm not
okay